and new tonight the Las Vegas Convention
Center Authority telling 8 news now that
325 thousand visitors are expected this
Super Bowl weekend and that hotel
occupancy is on Pace to exceed 93
percent welcome to town it makes sense
with the game on Sunday a whole lot of
people celebrating an early Valentine's
day as well local restaurants bracing
for a bigger crowd than usual this
weekend that is something that has
really become a trend more than ever in
Las Vegas
Valentine's Day is a huge day we had our
best year on record last year in 2022
and uh January this year Well exceeded
last January so we are very optimistic
about 2023. the chef went on to say that
the 400 reservations they have on the
books already there for the big day
Valentine's Day Denise